To show you how to register at these
activity lifecycle call backs,
I created a new project named Lifecycle.
And I used the empty
activity template and
in here I started modifying
the MainActivity file.
So I went through and overrode each of
the major activity lifecycle methods,
onCreate, onStart, onResume,
onPause, and so on.
And here I give you
an example of how I did that.
Now on my version of Android Studio I
have a keyboard shortcut
to pull up the override method menu.
So I have Ctrl+O and pulls up this
list of methods that I can override.
For here I want to choose onStop, click
OK, and that pulls in the method for me.
So Android Studio automatically
helped me add the method into my app.
Now within each method I'm going to call
a super class version of the method.
This will execute instructions
within the onStop method of
the AppCompatActivity.
And remember that's
the class that we overrode.
So this super class is the one that
does the real work in terms of
showing the window on the screen and
other behind the scenes stuff
that makes the activity work.
So whenever you override a lifecycle
method be sure to call the superclass
version of that method first now after
this line we can add in our own logic.
I add in a line of code that prints
out a log message with the name of
the method as well as what
activity lifecycle method is hit.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So once the app is running on my device,
the activity immediately launches and
I can check the logs and
see that onCreate, onStart and
the onResume methods have been called.
Now when I hit the Home button,
the activity is no longer visible.
So the onPause and the onStop
method should have been called and
here they are in the logs.
So we're doing good.
Now if I go back into my app.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Then the onStart and
onResume methods get called.
And then the activity is now active and
I can interact with it.
All right, so I know that was a lot
of information to take in and
it might be a hard concept
to grasp at first, but
don't worry as you see more scenarios
of this app and future apps,
you'll learn how to better
manage the activity lifecycle.
And if you'd like to experiment
with activity lifecycle methods,
I've linked the code that we've
looked at here down below.